hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Matt Welch
this is ask a libertarian 2012 we're
celebrating the paperback release at the
end of the month of the Declaration of
Independence how libertarian politics
can fix what's wrong with America latest
question comes from Elijah William EB
via Facebook Sweden he says Matt isn't
very libertarian but a lot of people
would rather live there isn't Sweden an
example of a far from libertarian place
that's a great place to live having
lived in Sweden couldn't really testify
kind of dispute the premise of the
question in that is Sweden taking in a
whole bunch of immigrants now I know
they're taking in quite a few but not
it's not the premier destination I think
from speaking personally I don't live or
even aspire to live in super libertarian
places the last three cities that I've
lived in our Los Angeles California the
District of Columbia and now New York
City probably three of the least
libertarian metropolis in this country
people I think choose where they live
based on a wide variety of thing public
policy isn't necessarily at the top of
that list I would point out that Sweden
I think has a much lower corporate tax
rates they have a kind of a cleaner
business climate than the u.s. does in
many ways shape forms they just have a
stronger kind of social safety net and a
lot of nanny laws about booze so I would
be hard for me to deal with that aspect
of it but I don't choose where I want to
live based on how libertarian are your
politics you know but the other thing to
think about as Sweden also reduced that
share of government spending as a
percentage of GDP in the 90s they had a
major banking problem that they cleaned
up in various ways when Saab went
bankrupt unlike in the u.s. the Swedish
government said so long that's it we're
not bailing you out pretty good Sweden
also has and has had for many many years
fully virtualized education so there are
things that Americans can learn from
Sweden just as there are many things
that Swedes can learn from America the
question is not is one place a paradise
in the other place a you know hell hole
but it's rather at any point in time how
can you make the area you live that you
choose to live in more
Taron more free more decentralized and I
think we definitely do have reasons to
learn from Sweden ask a libertarian 2012
keep on watch and keep on sending
questions